there are people in my audience and
elsewhere
who are getting too confident about the
upcoming presidential election
i'm scared by it you guys are scaring me
and so what i want to do today
is to make the case that not only could
donald trump win reelection nothing
major really needs to change for him to
win re-election
he could be winning right now from an
electoral college standpoint so
if you don't look at the details and you
say oh
biden's plus 10 biden's plus 12 there
was a poll where biden was plus 15
seems like biden's winning easily and
he's also winning key battleground
states biden is going to run away with a
historic electoral college victory
no no if by the end of this clip
i have not convinced you that we should
be very careful of interpreting the data
we have in that way
then i will have failed to do my job i
deserve to be
cancelled hello if by the end of this
segment i've not convinced you that we
need to be very very
careful about what's going on so let's
start with national polling
whenever there's a poll that says joe
biden is up 12.
joe biden is up 10. joe biden is up 15
it gets a ton of attention and certainly
if joe biden wins the popular vote by 10
12 or 15
trump's done that's not actually
what the mathematical case today is
let's look at the numbers today
and understand the numbers first of all
the polls that had biden up 10 12 and 15
we're not getting any more of those
polls okay the last poll where biden was
up double digits was july 23rd he was up
10.
more recently biden is only up 3 in a
number of polls
and on average biden is up by 6.4
6.4 is very different than 15 my friends
so
6.4 still sounds pretty good
but understand that if you look at any
individual poll you have to understand
the margin of error
hugely important so for example the
latest
yougov poll has a 3.3 percent
margin of error so when the yougov poll
says that biden is winning by 9 49 to 40
trump's 40 could actually be 43.3 and
it would still be within the margin of
error of the poll
biden's 49 could really be
45.7 so a poll which
promotes as a headline biden plus 9
could really be biden plus 2.4
and the poll would still be correct this
is what we
this is why we have a confidence
interval and a margin of error
if biden is really only winning by 2.4
trump could win the electoral college
remember we have
polling for the national popular vote
but we have an electoral college system
in 2016 hillary won the popular vote by
i think it was 2.1 or 2.2
but lost the electoral college so for
people who are saying
what could happen to allow trump to
catch up to biden
nothing has to happen within the margin
of error
today donald trump has the support
where he could win the electoral college
if we have similar
battleground results to those in 2016.
you don't need an october surprise
when the current lead for trump might
only be i'm sorry the current lead for
biden might only be 2.4
trump won 2016 with a 2.1
deficit in the popular vote so that's
national popular vote polling
let's now go to step two you might say
biden's winning hugely in key
battleground states well remember in
2016
the national popular vote polls were
accurate
but there were state polls that didn't
get it right
state polls had some problems in 2016.
so
hillary was winning the polling in
wisconsin going into the election
trump won wisconsin that's just one
example
so once you concede the national polling
that looks like a big lead for biden
could
actually be like a two-point lead for
biden state
polling was off in some states in 2016.
you have to come to the conclusion that
biden might not really be winning
electorally
right now and then lastly i talked about
this yesterday
when you look at voter registration
it doesn't look that great it is true
that in many states if you look only at
new registrations meaning people who
have never been registered before
who maybe were not even 18 years old in
2016. when you look just at
new registrations democrats have an
advantage over republicans
they've registered more new voters but
as i told you yesterday
in florida pennsylvania arizona iowa
north carolina in terms of the number of
registered
democrats versus republicans today
versus 2016
the advantage has been in favor of
republicans and against democrats
and the reasons for this are people who
have moved from one state to another
people who have switched party
registrations deaths
this is separate from who is going to
choose to vote
but this is not the type of data you
want to see if you want to be confident
that joe biden is going to run away with
this thing so when you step
back and you say well the polls
if you account for margin of error look
very similar to 2016.
there were state polls in 2016 that were
wrong and then you realize you know over
the next three months
if the economy improves a little bit if
coronavirus
gets better if we get a vaccine
or a good treatment that trump will try
to take
credit for a one or one and a half point
swing from where we are today in trump's
direction
and trump wins the electoral college so
i hope that i have convinced you that we
need to be
far more skeptical about these biden's
running away with it
ideas that we are starting to see you
must
run as if we are behind this is going to
be a huge fight
it actually doesn't look nearly as good
as some are claiming
and i'm very worried some of you are
worrying me
that we are getting complacent that some
people think the data
clearly points to biden running away
with this review this video
if you need to fact check me go
item by item and if you do
you can come to only one conclusion
which is that there is not
actually evidence to say right now that
joe biden is going to easily win in
november
he might win hugely and he might lose
and we're going to we're going to have
to fight this we're going to have more
coverage of this
on the show's instagram page david
pakman show is our instagram handle
while you are there you can also follow
me on instagram at david.pacman you
should see
what's going on in my backyard which you
can find out on my instagram
david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that
i have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video